ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้า
สวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงมาช้านะคะครูฟ้าวันนี้
วันอะไรคะวันนี้วันจันทร์ค่ะวันนี้วัน
จันทร์
Ok วันจันทร์ก็ได้ค่ะวันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันจันทร์ที่ติด 5
เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
สิงหาคม
ปีพศอะไรคะดีพ.ศ
ปีคศอะไรคะปีค.ศ
2022 ค่ะ
เมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรคะเมื่อวานนี้วัน
อาทิตย์วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวัน 4  24
เดือน
สิงหาคมปีพตตปีพ.ศ 2565  a คศปีคศ 2  022
ขาดพรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะ
พรุ่งนี้วันอังคาร
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 16
เดือน
สิงหาคมปีพตตปีพตต
2565 ปีคศปีคศ 2  022 ค่ะกะตอนนี้เวลา
กี่โมงคะคุณฟ้า
ตอนนี้เวลา 10:00 น 7 โมงกี่นาที
นี้ 10 โมง 18 นาทีค่ะ
10 โมง 18 นาทีนะคะตอน
เช้ากลางวันเย็น
ตอนสาย
ผู้หญิงพูดเช้ากลางวันเย็นครูมาต่อสายถูก
ค่ะผู้เขาพูดถูก
ตอนสายคือช่วงปิดโมง 11 โมงนะคะนักเรียน
ตอนสายๆเพราะว่าก็ไม่เช้าแล้วแล้วก็ไม่
ใช่เวลายังไม่ถึงกลางวันไหนกันแน่นอนสาย
นะคะวันนี้เนี่ยคุยมีเกมสนุกๆมาเล่นกับ
ครูฟ้าอีกแล้ว
เกมอะไรคะผู้หญิงที่เกมวันนี้นะคะครูฟ้า
กุ้ยกูฟ้าชมพูเชียวก็ฟ้าหัวดำเลยอ่ะคะ
อันนี้โหสั่งซื้อผมจะ
วัดผมสีฟ้าเนี่ยต้องคิด
เร็วจะไม่ต้องแบบเร็วมากว่าฟ้าต้องคิดคำ
ถามด้วย
คิดคำทหารหลวงคลิปต้อง
เอาคิดคำถามอะไรก็ได้ครูฟ้าต้องคิดคำถาม
ขามครูหญิง
แล้วค่ะผู้หญิงเนี่ยก็จะต้องคิดน่ะกูฟ้า
คิดถึงถามใช่ไหมแล้วก็กูหญิง
ผู้หญิงก็ต้องคิดคำตอบแต่ว่าคำตอบของครู
หญิงเนี่ยน้องตอบ 1  2  3  4
ตั้งค่าเว็บบอกเช่นนักเรียน
เห็น 1  3  4  5
ก็คือคำถามของครูฟ้าเนี่ยต้องให้ผู้หญิง
บอกคำตอบ 5 คำตอบโห้เฮ้ยคำตอบจ่ายค่ะพอ
เสร็จแล้วก็สลับกัน
ครูหญิงคิดคำถามค่ะฟ้าตอบคำถามเรามาจาก
สลับกัน
ได้ค่ะครีมดารา
คนคิดเกมใช่ไหมคะให้คุณนายเกตุอ่ะผู้หญิง
ห้ามคือฟ้าว่าอะไร
ครูหญิงถามครูฟ้าว่าให้ครูฟ้าบ่ข้อสอบครู
หญิง
วุฒิ
วันหยุด 5 วัน
วันยูโรทีมวันหยุดก็คือวันที่เราเนี่ยไม่
ต้องไปออฟฟิศจะไว้ไม่ต้องไปทำงานอยู่บ้าน
สบายๆ
คุณต้องตอบเลยนะฮะใช่ไหมกูก็ต้องบอกวัน
หยุดบอกวันหยุด 5 วัน
หนึ่งวันแม่ 2 วันพ่อ
นักเรียนไม่เข้าใจ
ด้วยไม่ต้องเร็วขนาดนั้นนึกว่าแรงโง่นาย
ห่าวันหยุดวันที่เราไม่ต้องไปออฟฟิศเนาะ
หนึ่ง
ประเทศไทยมีโอ้นี่วันแม่นางนักเรียนวัน
แม่นี้แม่และก็พ่อใช่ไหม
อ่านแผนตั้งแต่แล้วก็คือฟ้านิคฟ้า
พ่อแม่ลูกนะวันแม่คือมีห้า
วันของแม่นะวันของแม่ไฟฟ้าเนี่ยก็อาจจะ
ซื้อช็อกโกแลตช็อกโกแลตซื้อช็อกโกแลตให้
คุณแม่ซื้ออาหารให้คุณแม่ซื้ออะไรให้เป็น
แม่วัดวันที่เท่าไหร่วันที่
นะคะ a
12 สิงหาคมวันแม่มือวันนี้มีประเทศไทย
เป็นวันหยุดใช่ไหมมันหยุดใช่ค่ะหยุดหา
น.ส.อรสา
วันพ่อ
ไม่เข้าปลานะคะ
เรียนหมอถามนี่วันลูกหรือเปล่าติ๊ก
ลูกด้วยหรอเมลรูปไหมวันห้อหนาวันพ่อแล้ว
ก็วันพ่อในวันที่ 5 วัน
เบียนอะไรคะ
ธันวาคม
มันก็เอาสาววันหยุดวันอะไร
3  -
ไม่ที่ณ
3 เนี่ยควันปีใหม่
ทำไมเขาไม่เรียนหรอ
เรียนจากตอนนี้ใช่ไหมวันปีใหม่นะคะโอ้
เยปีใหม่มีไหมมีไหมวันปีใหม่ก็สิบเก้าแปด
เจ็ดหกห้าสี่สามสองหนึ่งเย้
วันปีใหม่นะคะหยุดไม่ต้องไปออฟฟิศ
ไปเขาดาวไปกินข้าวกับเพื่อนนะวันปีใหม่ AE
ล่ะคะวันหยุด 4
วันสงกรานต์
ดูหนูวันที่เท่าไหร่ล่ะวันสงกรานต์ก็มี
น้ำเนี่ยเป็นขวดนะคะข้างในมีน้ำแล้วก็สาด
ชาย 5 วันไอ้ขันหน้าดีกว่าว่าอยู่นะคะน
วันสงกรานต์วันที่ 1
อะไรนะเป็นร่วมมือน
มีเรื่องอะไรอ่ะ
เมษายนค่ะไม่สาเดือนอะไรคะพลังกุมพามีนา
เมสายนต์เดือนที่ 4 เดี๋ยวนี้ 453 เดือน
ที่ 4 นะคะ
apr
ขอบคุณบ้านลืมเอาไว้พี่ขอโทษนะช่วยก็ไม่
กิน
ไม่ได้กินนะคะวิตามินซีอาหารข้าว
คือนิสัย 25  3 วันสงกรานต์แล้วก็วันที่ 5
วันหยุดอีก 1 วันมันที่ 5 วันพฤกษ์ว่า
อยู่ไหน
อีกแล้วบอกเลยว่าอะไรก็ได้อาจจะไม่ใช่ที่
ไทยก็ได้ไงที่ไทยที่ไทยบางออฟฟิศก็หยุด
วันคริสต์มาสนี้กูฟ้าว่าเท่าไหร่คะสัตว์
ผมขอเสนอให้หาก
วันคริสต์มาสเออนั้นติดอยู่บนหัวนะคะ
ส่วนปากหอสระโฮะโหมันคิดวันที่ 25
เดือนอะไรนะอันหั่นว่าก็เหมือนวันพ่อค่ะ
อย่าลืมคนเขียนไปเมื่อกี้
ธันวาคมหน้านี้ก็เป็นวันหยุดเนาะวัน
คริสต์มาสครอบแล้วพวกโอกะครูหญิงนาฬิกาก็
สลับกันให้ครูฟ้าถามครูหญิงบ้างครูซ้าย
อยากให้ครูหญิงบอกอะไร 5 อย่างห้ามก็ยัง
ผู้หญิงบอก
ประเทศอ่ะค่ะคุณหญิง
อันนี้ลูกใช่ไหมคะเสือสาวฟ้ากระจ่าง
ดาวอ่ะ
หนึ่ง
ประเทศอะไร
อังกฤษ
ถ้าผู้หญิงคิดประเทศอังกฤษล่ะว่าผู้หญิง
ชอบใช่ไหมตายค่ะซ่อมแอร์รี่พอตเตอร์นะคะ
ขอสองประเทศ
ฝรั่งเศสระหว่างประเทศฉีดน้ำหอมเนอะ
สิริริน
ถึงน้ำหอม Christian  Dior  eau
ของฝรั่งเศสนะคะหลังเสนซะงั้น
ประเทศเยอรมันประเทศเจอนะมันเหนื่อยทำไม
รถ mercedes-benz ทหาร
4-4
สเปน
หน่อยฮะ
เจนสเปนมีแหล่งอาหารอร่อยแล้วกันเนาะ
อาหารอร่อยหรือเปล่าเราก็ถ้า
ประเทศ least  A และกรีซไวล่า
ทะเลสวยไงอาหารลิงค์
อิตาลีก็อีกอันนี้ไม่ทะเลสวยอะไรนะพูด
อะไรนะ
ครบแล้วเราผู้หญิงหญิงต่อลบแล้ว 555 ระ
เทศในยุโรปใช่ไหม 5 ประเทศในยุโรปอาจจะ
เป็นประเทศที่คุยชอบ
หรือเปล่ามันก็เลยเอาตัวไม่ติดคิดได้ทั้ง
นั้นไก่ค่ะก็ไม่ยากไงประเทศอ่ะคุณฟ้า
บอกว่าอยู่
เฮ้ยอ่ะหมดอันไหมอีกอันนึงฐานๆอะไรง่ายๆ
ให้ครูขวาบอก
อ่านอะไร
อ่ะ
ปุ๊บให้ครูเปิดฝาบอกกูเขาบอกให้ผู้หญิง
บอกค่าประเทศแล้วใช่ไหมคะให้ครูฝาบอก
นี้ไม่ยากหรอกบ้าน
บ้านใช่ไหมเราก็บอก 5 ห้องที่อยู่ในบ้าน
บ้านก็จะมีห้องห้องห้องห้องให้บอก 5 ห้อง
ที่อยู่ในบ้าน
5 ห้องที่อยู่ในบ้านนะคะหนึ่ง
ของอะไร
ห้องนอน
แต่
เอ้า
ห้องนอน 5 ห้องนอนเลยเราก็จะนอนห้องนอน
นั้นห้องนอนอันนี้เป็นหยัง
ก็
[เพลง]
ห้องนอน
อยู่หน้าห้อง 2 ห้องอะไร
2 ห้องน้ำค่ะห้องน้ำเดี๋ยว
ห้องน้ำห้องนอนแล้วก็อันนี้ห้องน้ำ
ห้องน้ำห้องน้ำ
3 ราคาห้องอะไร
ตา 3
ห้องครัว
เขาครัวราะทำอาหารทำงานต้องครัว
น้องสัว 4 หรอคะห้องอะไร
ห้องนั่งเล่นห้องนั่งเล่นเอาไว้ทำอะไรกู
ป่าก็จะมีทีวีใช่ไหม TV นะคะ TV แล้วก็จะ
มีโซฟา
ค่ะ
แล้วก็โซฟานะคะศพอ่า
ก็เอาไว้ดูทีวีห้องนั่งเล่นเนี่ยก็จะคุณ
พ่อคุณแม่สมัยมาดูทีวีด้วยกันนะคะน้อง 1
ใน
5 ห้องอะไรคะอีกหนึ่งห้อง
5  4 ห้องแล้วเก็บของอ่ะผู้หญิง
เก็บของแล้วไปทำอะไร
เพราะเข้าเก็บของเนี่ยถ้าสมมติกูฟ้ามี
เฟอร์นิเจอร์ที่ไม่ใช้เออหรือว่ามีทีวี
ที่ไม่โอเคแล้วใช่ไหมกูเขาก็เอาทีวีเอา
เฟอร์นิเจอร์เนี่ยไปเก็บในห้องเก็บของนะ
คะห้องเก็บของก็จะ
เข้าเก็บของก็ต้องติดแล้วก็ล๊อค
เก็บใครวะอ่าตุ๊กตาครูฟ้าของครูฟ้าตอน
เด็กๆสวยตอนนี้ครูฟ้าโตแล้วของตอนเด็กๆ
ไม่ใช้ก็เอาไปเก็บ
ในห้อง 2
กรองกล่องใช่ไหมกล่อง
มีพลาสติกอะไรอย่างเงี้ยที่ไม่ใช้ฮะเยอะๆ
กล่องกล่อง
[เพลง]
อันนี้ห้องเก็บของและห้องเก็บของค่ะมี
บันไดด้วยอีกหนึ่งค่ะ
เป็นห้องเก็บของนะคะ
r56 น้ำพบอยู่แล้วให้ครูฟ้าถามครูหญิง
กลับอีกหนึ่งคอ
ได้ยังไงเอ้อผู้หญิงบอกอะไรถ้าอย่าง
เฮ้ยอย่าง
อยากให้ครูหญิงบอกมี
อวัยวะในร่างกาย
ของยังไงหรอข้างนอกหมายถึงอวัยวะของเรา
นี่แหละอวัยวะของเรานี่เรียนอวัยวะก็คือ
เนี่ยนิ้วหิวตาจมูกปากหู
อวัยวะของเราน่ะค่ะอวัยวะที่กูหญิงชอบ
ผู้หญิงชอบข้ายังไม่ยางนะที่ผู้หญิงชอบนะ
เดินดู
หนึ่งจะมี
ผู้หญิงชอบจมูก
ใช่
ผู้หญิงบานคุกได้มันได้ตัวเองก็เลยชอบ 125
เอ๊ะ
ทำไมอ่ะ
ก็ฟันใหญ่เท่าๆกับครูฟ้าไงคะ
ชอบ
3 เล่นเล็บสปาเล็บ
เล็บ
ใส่ค่ะเล็บ
เพราะว่ารู้สึกว่าเล็บผู้หญิงแข็งแรงดี
มาก
ง้อสาวเล็บ 4 ละ
4 อะไรดีอ่ะผู้หญิงชอบอะไรไม่ชอบจมูกยัง
ชอบฟันผู้หญิงชอบเล็บคุณชอบอะไรอีก
มือมือ
ไม่ใช่นิ้วใช่ไหมมือซื้อมือนั้น
ก็รู้สึกว่ามือเนี่ยเบอร์ผู้หญิงไม่เล็ก
แล้วก็ไม่ใหญ่พอดีมาดีมือ
แล้วก็
555 อะไรฮะหิวคิ้วผู้หญิงชอบคิ้วหรอนะ
มั้ยหิวมีขนคิ้วนิดหน่อยนะคะชอบมีคนคิ้ว
คนคิ้วคนคิ้วล่ะพิมพ์นี่ก็เป็นอวัยวะ 5
อย่างมหาที่ครูอยู่ซ้อ
ครูหญิงมีคำถามให้นักเรียนถ้านักเรียนดู
มาจนจบนักเรียนก็จะ
เรียนก็จะได้ยินได้ฟังคำถามแค่นั้นล่ะค่ะ
คำถามอะไรเค้าหญิงเอ้าให้นักเรียนเนี่ย
บอกอาหารไทยที่อร่อยที่สุดเหมาะสำหรับนัก
เรียนมา 5 อย่าง
งานไปอาหารไทย 5 อย่างกินนักเรียนคิดว่า
แบบอร่อยที่สุดนะถ้านักเรียนอยากตอบก็
คอมเม้นข้างล่างนะคะเดี๋ยวกินลาบให้อาหาร
ไทยอะไรเฮ้ยอย่างที่อร่อยที่สุดนะได้เลย
ว่าไม่มีคนนี้แหละคุยกับครูฝาต้องไปแล้ว
ไปแล้วค่ะแล้วเจอกันใหม่วิดีโอหน้านะคะ
บ๊ายบายสวัสดีค่ะอ่ะ